après trois semaines de rebondissements
et de fausses pistes l'enquète sur le
meurtre du petit grégory semble ce soir
touché près de son but
le 16 octobre 1984 le jeune grégory âgé
de 4 ans est retrouvé ligoté dans la
vologne une rivière des vosges
c'est le début d'une des plus grandes
énigmes criminelles françaises
et pourtant le criminel semblait avoir
été vite démasqué grâce aux aveux d'une
jeune fille muriel bolle muriel aurait
reconnu s'être trouvé dans la voiture de
la roche avec son fils sébastien
tous les trois serait allé chercher
grégory pour se rendre derrière la
caserne des pompiers de docelles bernard
laroche se répartit quelques instants
avec grégory il est revenu seul mériel
bol alors âgé de 15 ans accuse bernard
laroche son beau-frère du meurtre du
petit grégory
c'est à vous de se pendre ses aveux
déclenché une réaction en chaîne à la
gendarmerie de bruz hier il est alors 12
heures et tout va s'accélérer
le juge d'instruction et les gendarmes
prennent la direction de grand-champ
vologne et vont arrêter bernard laroche
sur son lieu de travail aux
établissements cancel la roche en
ressentira les menottes aux poignets les
médias s'emballent et ballet la
présemption d'innocence
ce matin pendant deux ans et demi jean
michel lambert le juge d'instruction a
reconstitué avec muriel le trajet
supposé de l'assassin de grégory et à
l'issue de la reconstitution le juge
déclaré je suis optimiste
on brûle le juge d'instruction quant à
lui n'organise pas de confrontation
entre muriel et son beau frère
et livrent certains détails à la presse
en dépit du secret d'instruction muriel
à accompagner bernard laroche sur les
lieux du crime
elle était dans la voiture et sébastien
son fils aussi oui c'est lui qui a servi
d'appât pour vraiment vraiment pas
vraiment bien son nom est-ce que j'étais
dans la voiture
muriel bolle devient le témoin clé de la
faire mais après une soirée dans sa
famille elle revient sur ses aveux
les larmes aux yeux face aux
journalistes vers narines sans mon gros
frais les unes et sans jamais été avec
mon beau-frère
ensuite c'est le silence malgré
l'assassinât de bernard laroche par le
père du petit grégory
malgré les récentes garde à vue jamais
plus muriel bolle ne reviendra sur ses
déclarations accusant son confrère
aujourd'hui à la veille de ses 50 ans
elle est toujours considérée par
certains comme la victime d'un naufrage
judiciaire
pour d'autres comme celle qui c est qui
se tait
[Musique]